[Music]
[Applause]
Miravalle
main review everybody YouTube favorites
show let's see how the last video did
did it Universal Pictures didn't like
that I mean their guru mean excuse me
you used my meme in the picture so now
all the revenue is mine that's right
this is censorship how am I supposed to
be a reviewer if I can't even review the
means Universal I see you in court but
no time to try like a little crybaby of
course we have to get into the means yes
what ma'am this PT Pinewood here we
selected this time I wonder mmm
dog meme sorry I just look at that dog
and I can't help myself
dog meme is needs no introduction it's
the greatest meme of all time it's a
picture of a dog not just any dog but a
Shiba Inu which has now become sort of a
staple of the breed of dog Ness such Wow
MRI guy's dog even has bitcoins now dog
coin that seems like a solid investment
it's funny cuz it's a meme mixed with
finance and business and currency that's
hilarious I cry every time it's even
crying through his nose the thing about
the doggie doggie meme dodge mean it's a
baby's a bitumen anymore for yak that's
right he can morph into other shapes
which is to mean that I'm reviewing
today that's right we have this dog
turning into a a rat a mole rat what we
have dodged turning into elephant
that is crazy you had dodged turning
into sperm son less sperm cell has
arrived
oh I see it
people are photoshopping dodge into
different things using the liquefying
Photoshop tool the car has arrived
the bat has arrived the fact that to
imagine if dodge was a bad if I cannot
inspire love I will cause fear is that
Jar Jar Binks this meme is a meme that
just keeps on giving what are they going
to liquify next who knows it could be
anything a snail
let's snail has arrived everybody Lavar
excitedly bowl of virus that is so
clever let is a mix of like your uber
driver has a rider why is it laying look
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter in
the memes Felix stupid German Legere
money has arrived you get points for
creativity let me just say that what in
the that looks good
that's impressive wait I wonder if I can
do this like myself it shouldn't be that
hard
[Music]
here diff hi has arrived everybody 2016
PewDiePie has never left us he just went
into a furry face as we all do at least
one point in my life then realizing oh
god that's disgusting what kind of what
kind of weird upbringing David did I
have to bring out these strange sexual
desires love bog has arrived this meme
of course is there just like any other
meme a meme of another meme like any
other means there's another meme of
another mean like any other meme it's
another meme of another meme of another
[Music]
nation of the spaghetti meme where you
have memes inside spaghetti so funny
such Wow such clever or having any maybe
ice has anyone done an anime dodge
liquify Photoshop get on that right now
gonna rate this meme of course yes yeah
for it gets a 4 it's not bad could be
better but not bad he gets for doggie
dogs next right there was a shot me
attend me we have the hard to swallow
pills meme how much of ironic life and
can you endure for 10 minutes and keep
watching guys incognito does not save
you from the FBI what wait wait are you
serious
hard to swallow pills casual
conversations does not mean she likes
you
oh my god this meme is spitting truth
bombs [ __ ] ciao boom it goes damn
hard to swallow pills soon Star Wars
will no longer be special due to over
saturation oh wow you must be extremely
woke to have made this mean this means
gets at least five worthless points it's
not like Star Wars isn't oversaturated
already are you kidding me it's a
billion-dollar industry what do you mean
are not oversaturated are you seriously
that stupid are you still living in your
own little club that Star Wars or
somewhere precious and special what does
this mean twenty years ago [ __ ] hard to
swallow pills nobody cares about your
fortnight wins oh my gosh I've been
saying this for such a longest time no
one cares
absolutely no one cares about your fault
lengua it's obviously not that
impressive it's actually kind of shot
you just said in camp for what thirty
minutes and then you come in for the
bush and be like oh god um hahahahahaha
aren't i special
I beat a hundred people no you didn't
you were the only one that actually
spent 30 minutes doing football hard to
swallow pants a dead group chat means
your friend made a new one without you
hard to swallow Paris you know a meme is
dead when it's reviewed on meme review
jokes on you i made this meme hard to
swallow pills your mommy so much alright
you swallow pill your pets don't
genuinely love you they just have a case
of Stockholm Syndrome which is where you
develop a bond when York after Edgar
tell them I love you that is Swahili for
I finally found it after 15 years the
scroll of truth the heart to swallow
pills meme is the new version of this
name so woke this meme gets 5000 volt
points because my god next we'll never
back are you ready for this one we saved
the best for last
can I go to toilet
I don't know can you teacher nice people
how do I explain this mean without okay
all right it's a mean fifth graders
after they jump up and touch the top of
the doorway the most satisfying
sensation of all time and whenever you
see anyone else do that [ __ ] you've got
to do it as well
you just have to do there's no way you
cannot do that gay people says what what
third grade gasps says seventh grade
gasps when someone says orgasm instead
of organism in me I'm not hungry
grandma gasps they always want to stuff
your face what's up with that guy's
six-month-old minion meme gets posted on
Facebook mom gasps teacher it's raining
out so today is indoor recess elementary
school gasps are you gay no does your
mom know you're gay no say I spell map
and Shane s I am a pee
kill commies for school Gordon say
spring bill snap and Apple Engels spring
cars snow pen uh-oh
run car snow pen oh my god it actually
worked
run ghost not bad me this me mister
blessing to earth and cured all my
depressions all six of them this gets us
catch the 9.25 I don't know how you're
feeling you're feeling anxious you're
feeling nervous is there going to be a
bonus meme this week it's getting mighty
close to 10 minutes and in fact it has
already been more than 10 minutes so you
know it's not gonna be time for bonus
mean but I do see that there's the leads
one more minute of this video so perhaps
that means that it's time for boners
mean but just a little small bonus mean
not a really long bonus me but just
maybe like a few funny ones to where I
can go out just for a little longer I
really need bonus meme I had a tough
week I had a tough month in general I
had a tough life and I could really use
there being some boners meme right now
so let's spend the wheel everybody is
there time for boners me
[Music]
sorry no time for bonus mean
better luck next week